i can't believe we've come to the end of
the show
ruby do you have a favorite part today
you know the entire day was my favorite
but i do have one small favorite piece
it was when adam sang
happy birthday to me
i mean hello i mean i had chills chill
hello bucket list check yeah yes that
was um that was really special it was
like we've all heard happy birthday our
entire lives he put a whole new spin on
it but adam lambert the best the best
well thank you ruby thanks for having me
thank you so much for having me it was
so fun so much to do this show with you
we wanted to give you something for all
your great work so um we are uh
literally um making you our employee of
the month
[Applause]
but is more importantly we're going to
send you and a friend off to the sandbar
rooftop in manhattan for dinner this
this amazing place that's outdoors
cocktails sophisticated menu and amazing
views of the city and we just would like
to buy you some cocktails and food and
have an evening on us yes thank you oh
my gosh thanks so much
thank you all so much for being here um
we make this show for you so we hope
that you can take this with you
and the good energy and everything and
just thank you for choosing to spend
your time with us
[Music]
you